hey this is press tow
Walker here are two nice logical
puzzles problem one you need to figure
out a four-digit code and you're given
some
Clues
9285 one number is correct but in the
wrong
position 1
937 two numbers are correct but in the
wrong
positions
5201 one number is correct and in the
right
position
6507 nothing is correct
8524 two numbers are correct but in the
wrong
positions can you figure out the
four-digit
code problem two two logicians A and B
each secretly pick a whole number from 1
to 30 inclusive each knows the other has
done this the following conversation
takes
place a asks is your number double mine
B replies I don't know is your number
double mine a replies I don't know is
your number half mine B replies I don't
know is your number half mine a says I
don't know B exclaims I know your
number all the statements are true
what is a's number and how did B know I
saw this on Reddit
riddles pause the video if you'd like to
give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve these
problems let's solve problem one when I
see a puzzle like this I approach it by
looking at one of the
clues if you have a clue where nothing
is correct I think that's a good place
to start because it gives a lot of
information so we know
657 all of these digits are wrong so now
let's look at the last clue we know that
the digit five is wrong so we have 8 2
and four of these three digits we know
two numbers are correct so the correct
numbers could be 2 and 8 2 and 4 or 4
and8 these are the only three
possibilities now let's look at the
first clue
9285 one number is correct but in the
wrong position now we know five is wrong
of two and 8 we know that exactly one of
them must be correct because the
possibilities are 28 24 and 48
furthermore the clue says one number is
correct so we can't can't have both two
and eight being correct so we can
eliminate two and eight being
correct but if one of these is correct
that means nine has to be wrong because
otherwise we would have two correct
numbers so we figured out a lot from
this clue so the correct numbers are
either 2 and four or 4 and 8 furthermore
nine is the wrong number so we'll take
this information to the clue 1
1937 now we know nine is wrong and we've
also figured out that seven is wrong
from before now two numbers are correct
but in the wrong positions so that means
1 and three must be correct
numbers we can then look at the clue
5201 one number is correct and in the
right position we know that one is a
correct number so this has to be the
correct number and in the right position
previously we figured out that five is
wrong and that zero is wrong
so we've now figured out that two is a
wrong number so we can eliminate two as
a number in the first clue and we can
eliminate two in the final clue so two
and four is wrong and that means four
and eight are correct numbers so we
figured out the correct numbers are 1 3
4 and 8 so we just need to figure out
their
order now we've already figured out that
one is in the correct position in the
fourth
position from clue one we know that
eight is not in the third position and
from the last clue we know that eight is
not in the first position so that means
eight must be in the second position now
from the second clue we know that three
is not in the third position the spots
for two and four are already taken up so
three must be in the first position and
that means the number four is in the
third position so the correct code is 3
8 4 and
1 what an interesting
puzzle now let's solve problem
two let's label the logicians As A and B
at first a only knows that B has a
number from 1 to 30 inclusive and B also
thinks the same thing about a's number
all numbers are
possible so a asks is your number double
mine e replies I don't know if B had an
odd number then B would be able to say
his number is not Double A's number so
since B has said I don't know that means
B's number must be even because it
possibly could be double of another
number so a can eliminate all of the odd
numbers as possibilities for B's
numbers then B asks is your number
double mine a replies I don't
know a already knows that B's number is
an even number so in order for a's
number to be possibly double that it has
to be double an even number which means
that a's number must be a multiple of
four so B can eliminate all other
possibilities they're just left with the
possibilities of 4 8 12 16 16 20 24 and
28 a then asks is your number half mine
B replies I don't
know B knows that a's number has a
minimum value of four a maximum value of
28 and it's a multiple of four in order
that b replies I don't know it must be
the case that B's number is between 2
and
so a can eliminate all other
possibilities we know the maximum can be
14 so a eliminates all the possibilities
of numbers larger than 14 from
B then B asks is your number half
mine a says I don't know now let's look
at half of the possibilities for B's
numbers it'll be 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 so in
order that that a says I don't know it
has to be one of these numbers but
looking at the list that b already knows
the only commonality will be the number
four so B can deduce that a's number is
four and finally B says I know your
number so a's number is four and this is
how B is able to deduce it what an
incredible puzzle thanks for making us
one of the best communities on you
YouTube see you next episode of mind
your decisions where we solve The
World's problems one video at a
time